meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
lassen Sie mich zunächst zu beginnen
sagen dass wir den
Dank und die Erleichterung Teilen die
Sie Herr Bundeskanzler zu Beginn ihrer
Regierungserklärung zum Ausdruck
gebracht haben im Hinblick auf die
Freilassung wenigstens einer einiger der
Geiseln die sich in den letzten Wochen
in der Hand der hamasterroristen in
Israel befunden haben und ich will
ausdrücklich im Namen unserer Fraktion
sagen wir danken denjenigen die aus
ihrer Regierung daran beteiligt waren
dies zu erreichen ausdrücklich
herzlichen Dank an
Sie meine Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir sprechen
heute so war es
jedenfalls bis zum Beginn der Rede Herr
Bundeskanzler mein Eindruck über die
Folgen der Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes vom
15 November das Bundesverfassungsgericht
hat eine Entscheidung getroffen die den
Haushaltsgesetzgeber im Bund und in den
Ländern in Zukunft zu einer strikten
Ausgabendisziplin
verpflichtet diese Entscheidung ist in
der Sache richtig sie kommt zum
richtigen Zeitpunkt und sie war vor
allem notwendig lassen Sie mich das
einmal deutlich
sagen weil darüber ein falscher Eindruck
auch in Teilen der veröffentlichten
Meinung entstanden ist wir haben über
dieses Urteil nicht
triumphiert uns ist uns ist die
Tragweite dieser Entscheidung des
Verfassungsgerichtes sehr wohl
bewusst aber Herr
Bundeskanzler
igorden weil ihre Regierung den Versuch
unternommen hat die Verschuldungsgrenzen
des Grundgesetzes in einer in bisher in
Deutschland nicht gekannten gerade zu
dreisten Art und Weise zu
[Applaus]
umgehen von den Rednern der Koalition
hier gleich vorgetragen werden das war
weder eine Klage von uns gegen den
Klimaschutz noch gegen die notwendigen
Hilfen für die privaten Haushalte und
die Unternehmen in Deutschland noch war
sie dagegen gerichtet was auch frühere
Regierungen schon einmal versucht haben
das war eine Klage die gegen die bereits
in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag
aufgeschriebene von jeder bisherigen
stspraxis abweichenden Manipulation
unserer
Verfassung notwendig geworden
war eine Vereinbarung in ihrem
Koalitionsvertrag die dem Ziel
diente zum einen dem Wunsch der FDP zu
entsprechen auf Steuererhöhungen und auf
die Aussetzung der Schuldenbremse zu
verzichten und zum anderen die
ungehemmte Subvention allerl Projekte
der Bundesregierung weiter zu
ermöglichen und zum dritten die
aufblehung des Sozialstaates für die
Sozialdemokraten zu ermöglichen diese
Quadratur des Kreises haben sie versucht
und dieses Kartenhaus ist am 15 November
203 zusammengebrochen das war das
Ergebnis der Entscheidung von
karlsur und meine Damen und Herren der
Urheber der Urheber dieser
verfassungswidrigenonstr
war kein geringerer als sie Herr
Bundeskanzler sie haben nämlich in der
Übergangszeit der früheren Regierung auf
die neue Regierung noch in ihrer
Funktion als
Bundesfinanzminister genau diese wie wir
heute nun dezidiert Wissen
verfassungswidrige Konstruktion erdacht
dazu hätte ich von ihnen
erwartet nachdem Sie nun eine eine
solche Niederlage vor dem
Verfassungsgericht haben einstecken
müssen übrigens schon die zweite in
wenigen Wochen dazu hätten wir erwartet
dass es wenigstens mal ein Wort des
Bedauerns von ihn gegeben hätte wenn
nicht auch ein Wort der Entschuldigung
hier angebracht gewesen wäre Herr
Bundeskanzler sie wissen doch sonst
immer alles vor allem wissen Sie immer
alles besser als alle anderen sie haben
hier eben die 41 Seiten sie haben hier
eben die Vorentscheidung zitiert ihnen
aus dieser Vorentscheidung nicht
aufgefallen welche konkreten drei Punkte
das Bundesverfassungsgericht genannt hat
für die Hauptsache Entscheidung die dann
anschließend genauso gefolgt ist wie
eine ganze Reihe von Fachleuten der
Bundesrat ihre Mitglieder in der
Bundesregierung doch teilweise auch
ihnen vorausgesagt haben sie hätten es
wissen können was das
bundesverfassungsricht am 15 November
2023 entscheidet Absturz eines
besserwissers nennt das der Spiegel in
seiner Titelgeschichte in dieser Woche
und besser hätte es gar nicht
beschrieben werden
können nun will ich nicht nur hier
Kritik üben heute morgen sondern ich
will mich weil es gerade von ihnen so
viel Zwischenrufe gibt ich will mich bei
einem Mitglied der Bundesregierung auch
einmal ausdrücklich und sehr herzlich
danken das ist der Vizekanzler Herr
habbeck sie haben es für richtig
gehalten bei ihrem Parteitag in der
letzten Woche meine Partei die CDU als
eine Partei aus den 90er Jahren zu
bezeichnen damit habe ich gerechnet dass
das bei ihnen kommt vielen Dank ich
empfinde es nämlich wirklich als ein
großes Kompliment was sie da gesagt
haben wir hatten nämlich wir hatten in
den 90er Jahren Wirtschaftsminister auf
der Regierungsbank sitzen die wirklich
etwas von Wirtschaftspolitik verstanden
haben
wir
hatten wir
hatten wir hatten
Außenminister wir hatten Außenminister
auf der Regierungsbank sitzen die nicht
mit erhobenem Zeigefinger durch die Welt
gereist sind die überall hoch anerkannt
waren und von denen kein einziger auf
den Gedanken gekommen wäre sich bei
einer israelresolution bei den Vereinten
Nationen für Deutschland der Stimme zu
enthalten kein einziger auf die Idee
gekommen und wir hatten wir hatten einen
Finanzminister wir hatten einen
Finanzminister Theo Weigel der in 10
Jahren trotz größter fiskalischer
Herausforderungen Deutschland sicher in
die Währungsunion geführt hat und Herr
Bundeskanzler wir hatten mit Helmut Kohl
einen Bundeskanzler auf der
Regierungsbank sitzen der mit der
deutschen Einheit mit dem europäischen
Binnenmarkt und mit der Währungsunion
wirklich Geschichte für Deutschland und
Europa geschrieben hat davon sind sie
doch Lichtjahre entfernt insbesondere
mit der Regierungserklärung die sie
heute morgen hier abgegeben
haben nun kann man ja vom Rednerpult aus
nicht immer die Regierung jeden Tag und
jede Minute hier anschauen aber wenn sie
mal gesehen hätten wie ihre Regierung
hier welchen Gesichtsausdruck ihre
Regierung bei ihrer Regierungserklärung
hatte meine Damen und Herren das ist
jetzt heute das ist die Regierung der
viertgrößten Volkswirtschaft der Welt es
ist einfach es ist einfach nur noch
peinlich was wir von ihnen hier sehen
und
hören und Herr Bundeskanzler Herr
Bundeskanzler sie haben sie haben im
Februar des letzten Jahres von dieser
Stelle aus eine viel beachtete
Regierungserklärung abgegeben mit dem
Wort Zeitenwende dieses Wort findet in
ihrer regierungsh heute Erklärung heute
keine Erwähnung mehr was sie hier
vorgetragen haben sind doch rein
technische Antworten auf eine
hochpolitische Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes sie sind ein
klemner der macht ihnen fehlt jede
Vorstellung davon wie dieses Land sich
in den nächsten Jahren weiterentwickeln
soll sie haben keine Ahnung von dem was
da in den nächsten Jahren auf sie und
auf uns zukommt es tut mir herzlich leid
aber ich muss es nach dieser ich muss es
nach dieser Regierungserklärung einmal
so sagen ich will es nicht
überstrapazieren und will ihnen nicht zu
viele Vergleiche zumuten aber verglichen
allein mit den Kanzlern die ihre
einstmals so stolze Partei die SPD hier
in Deutschland gestellt hat verglichen
mit Willi Brand verglichen mit Helmut
Schmidt sogar mit sogar mit Gerhard
Schröder muss man doch spätestens nach
dieser Regierungserklärung von heute
morgen zu dem Schluss kommen sie können
es nicht die
Schuhe die Schuhe in denen sie
stehen die Schuhe in denen sie stehen
als Bundeskanzler der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland die sind ihnen mindestens
zwei schuhnummern zu groß anders kann
man es nicht sagen nachdem was wir heute
morgen hier von ihnen gehört
haben aber die Lage unseres Landes ist
zu ernst als dass wir daran nun Freude
haben könnten sie gefährden mit ihrer
Politik den Wohlstand und die Zukunft
unseres Landes vor allem die Zukunft
unserer Kinder und Enkelkinder wir
müssen möglicherweise damit rechnen dass
sie nach den letzten Turbulenzen in
ihrer Koalition der letzten zwei Woche
jetzt noch versuchen zwei Jahre über
Wasser zu bleiben und die Streitereien
und die Konflikte in ihrer Koalition
einfach so weitergehen und damit die
nachfolgenden Redner der Koalition hier
sofort die Antwort von mir bekommen sie
werden uns wieder an unsere
staatspolitische Verantwortung erinnern
die wir in diesem Lande tragen ja das
werden sie ja tun so ich will ihn ich
will ihn meine Damen und Herren ich will
Ihnen die Antwort geben was wir als
staatspolitische Verantwortung unserer
Fraktion empfinden die wichtigste ist
ihnen auf die Finger zu schauen und wann
immer dies notwendig ist dafür zu sorgen
dass sie jedenfalls mit den uns zur
Verfügung stehenden Mitteln dazu
gezwungen werden unsere Verfassung
einzuhalten das ist zunächst ein das
allerwichtigste und nur damit
sie und damit sie nicht wieder damit sie
nicht wieder überrascht sind was dann
möglicherweise das
bundesverfassungsricht später
entscheidet will ich Sie daran erinnern
dass noch fünf Verfahren vor dem
Bundesverfassungsgericht gegen ihre
Regierung anhängig sind zur Wahlprüfung
hier in Berlin zum heizungsgesetzung zum
heizungsgesetz zur Verkürzung der
informations und auskunftflichten des
Parlaments zur Verweigerung eines
Untersuchungsausschusses in Sachen
scholz-wburg ein einmaliger Vorgang in
der Parlamentsgeschichte dass
Minderheitenrechte des Parlamentes so
missachtet werden wie von ihnen und
schließlich gegen die Manipulation des
Wahlrechts darauf können Sie sich
einstellen für die nächsten Wochen und
Monate weitere Entscheidungen des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes legen Sie
sich diese Liste ganz oben auf Ihren
Schreibtisch damit sie nicht vergessen
was das bundesverfassungsricht noch zu
entscheiden hat in den nächsten
Wochen
unsere unsere staatspolitische
Verantwortung besteht außerdem darin
Ihnen immer dann wenn wir es in der
Sache für richtig halten zuzustimmen und
an den Gesetzen unseres Landes
konstruktiv mitzuwirken das haben wir in
den letzten zwei Jahren getan ja meine
Damen und Herren es ist ihnen
möglicherweise entgangen mich hat's auch
etwas überrascht aber wir haben mehr als
der Hälfte der Gesetze ihrer Koalition
im Deutschen Bundestag zugestimmt
manchem vielleicht hätten wir gar nicht
zustimmen sollen wir haben es getan aus
Überzeugung weil auch Kompromisse
notwendig sein müssen hier im Parlament
unsere staatspolitische
antw unsere staatspolitische
Verantwortung meine Damen und Herren
besteht auch darin vorschlagchläge zu
machen wie wir wieder auf einen Weg
zurückkehren können mit
umweltverträglichem Wachstum und hoher
Beschäftigung ohne dabei unsere
Staatshaushalte zu ruinieren und damit
Sie sich bitte keine Illusionen machen
damit Sie sich bitte keine Illusionen
machen wir werden an der Schuldenbremse
des Grundgesetzes festhalten und
versuchen Sie erst gar nicht versuchen
Sie erst gar
nicht versuchen Sie erst gar nicht einen
Keil in die Union zu treiben wir
versuchen Sie es erst gar nicht
versuchen Sie es nicht meine Damen und
Herren die Entscheidungen werden hier im
Deutschen Bundestag getroffen und nicht
im Rathaus von Berlin wir entscheiden
hier darüber wo wir entscheiden hier
darüber und wir reden und meine Damen
und Herren wir reden nicht nur wir reden
nicht nur über Nachhaltigkeit in der
Umweltpolitik wir reden auch über
Nachhaltigkeit in den Staatsfinanzen und
wir werden ihnen nicht die Hand dazu
reichen wieder zurückzufallen in die
alten sozialdemokratischen Muster einer
stetig steigenden Staatsverschuldung und
übrigens an dieser Stelle Herr
Bundeskanzler
Bundeskanzler da stehen in den nächsten
Tagen da stehen in
den da stehen in den nächsten Tagen in
Brüssel einige Entscheidungen zur
Wirtschafts und Währungsunion und zur
Fortsetzung des stabilitäts- und
wachstumspaktes an wir müssen ihnen
dabei helfen dass auch Deutschland ein
klares Signal der stabilen
Staatsfinanzen in der Währungsunion
kommt wenn in Deutschland die Dämme
brechen werden sie auch in allen anderen
Ländern der Währungsunion nicht halten
da hat Deutschland eine Vorbildfunktion
und die müssen sie ob sie wollen oder
nicht auch Wahn
und dann sage ich ih sehr konkret dann
sage ich ihn sehr konkret zu den Themen
wo wir Ihnen anbieten etwas besser zu
machen wenn Sie Ihre wirtschaftsenergie
und Umweltpolitik neu ausrichten wollen
mit wirklicher Technologie Offenheit und
mit marktwirtschaftlichen Instrumenten
wie ja ich weiß bei diesem Wort
reagieren sie sofort allergisch
Marktwirtschaft verstehen sie überhaupt
nicht können sie nicht mehr schreiben
geschweige denn auch wirklich Politik
machen damit meine Damen und Herren wenn
sie das wollen statt der staatlichen
Steuerung und Subvention aller
Transformationsprozesse dann haben sie
uns an Ihrer Seite wenn Sie
Arbeitsmarktpolitik ändern wollen mit
dem Ziel einer mit dem Ziel einer
vernünftigen Balance zwischen fördern
und fordern wenn Sie wollen dass sich
Beschäftigung im Arbeitsmarkt immer und
grundsätzlich mehr lohnt als der Bezug
von Transferleistungen dann haben sie
uns an ihrer
Seite
und wenn Sie darauf verzichten wollen
unter der Überschrift der
Kindergrundsicherung zunächst einmal
5000 neue Stellen im öffentlichen Dienst
zu schaffen wenn Sie darauf verzichten
wollen her Bundeskanzler dann haben sie
uns an ihrer Seite und wenn sie
überhaupt einmal aufhören dieses Land
bis mit einer bisher nie gekannten
Bürokratie zu überziehen dann haben sie
uns an ihrer Seite und Herr
Bundeskanzler wenn Sie mit uns reden
wollen wie wir das gegebenenfalls
gemeinsam auf den Weg bringen dann
kommen Sie gern zu mir und dann können
wir über fast alles miteinander reden
aber wenn sie aber wenn sie mit ihrer
Regierung so weitermachen wie bisher und
ihre Regierungserklärung von heute
Morgen gibt einen das sichere Gefühl
dass sie keinerlei Veränderungen an dem
vornehmen wollen was sie in ihrer
Rechthaberei in den letzten Wochen und
Monaten hier gesagt und getan haben wenn
sie weiter uneinsichtig sind wenn sie
weiter streiten wenn sie weiter unsere
Staatsfinanzen gefährden und unsere
Volkswirtschaft vor die Wand fahren dann
werden wir alles dafür tun dass der Spuk
mit ihrer Bundesregierung so schnell wie
möglich beendet wird meine Damen und
Herren das ist die staatspolitische
Verantwortung der Opposition in diesem
Deutschen Bundestag mit ihrer
Bundesregierung Herr Bundeskanzler der
Bundesrepublik
Deutschland
ein sehr kämpferischer oppositionsschiff
der hier quasi den Bundeskanzler
persönlich Angriff und wie schrieb eben
ein Kollege in einer Agentur zerlegt hat
sie sind ein klemtner der macht ihnen
fehlt jegliche Vorstellung wie sie sich
das Land fortentwickeln soll verglichen
mit Brand Schmidt Schröder muss man
spätestens nach der Regierungserklärung
heute morgen sagen und feststellen sie
können es nicht Herr Bundeskanzler sie
gefährden mit ihrer Politik den
Wohlstand und die Zukunft unserer Kinder
das war eine Rede die alles andere als
hoffnungsfroh für die in die Zukunft
blicken lässt dass es vielleicht doch
noch so etwas wie eine gemeinsame große
Anstrengung in diesem Land geben könnte
zusammen mit der CDU CSU um die Probleme
der Zukunft gemeinsam zu lösen ich
glaube jedem in der Ampel ist nach dem
heutigen Tag zumindest klar das muss die
Ampel Miteinander regeln vor allen
Dingen auch die Frage wie nun der
Haushalt 2024 aussehen soll was wo
gestrich wird und wo weiter investiert
werden kann diese Frage müssen die Koal
Koalitionäre untereinander regeln dazu
hat der Bundeskanzler relativ wenig
gesagt aber er hat gesagt Gründlichkeit
geht vor Schnelligkeit was darauf
schließen lässt dass er eher zu denen
gehört der sagt es kommt nicht unbedingt
darauf an vor Weihnachten diesen
Haushalt hier noch abzuschließen oder in
diesem Jahr gar da gab es schon die
Überlegung zwischen den Jahren eventuell
vor allen aus der Sozialdemokratie das
hörte sich beim bundeskanstler ganz
anders an